prova
c'è un buio c'è un buio spegnere come
farei fare come spegnere luci
no no con la voce dei siri spegne toni
[Risate]
ei sì basta riguardano questa scena
fissa dei siri spegne toni ha comprato
le luci quelle intelligenti che lea
rinominate toni e quando dicevi accendi
toni si riaccende toni e spegne toni che
sarebbe la luce oggi siamo amico mio
prego dimmi dove siamo
siamo sul poster ball cioè che è un
gioco di tostapane cioè do sol perché
palla tosta il posto da padre vuol dire
che giochiamo a palle coli tostapane
tu sei a destra io sono a sinistra ci
vuol dire che sui ce l'hai la webcam in
32 mi disse tu io quindi egli io sono
quella sinistra devo segnare la tua
parte di destra tumi disegnar sinistro
che mai
vediamo questo caso poi colpisci lancia
la palla in questo modo progetti fare
così divulgarla nella mia porta cosa che
è molto difficile ai due toast per
poterlo fa che si bruciano tanto tempo
la riprende pesino sul ciglio della
porta sto male però non ce la farei mai
oh guarda guarda comuni tosto no no no
ok sto male ha poi riprenderli tosto ma
non è vero l'ho preso
oddio è difficilissimo sì però mi stai
facendo soltanto favore è ma è
difficilissimo prenderlo
no no no no no stai ok c'è chi guarda
noi si è messo davanti handanovic
ok
do il mio avevo guarda quanto era bassa
la mia non poter mai insegnarti non
poterlo devi saltare con tutti e due
visto che non hai tosta
no non è vero no no sono arrivato a metà
campo a tirarti non è il gioco più bello
del mondo questa attenzione
gg wow wow tour ha pensato ecco il tuo
posto guarda c'è chi l'ha inventato e un
gesto che problemi abbia mai mi piace
uno stupro sì esatto lo prendo non è
vero invece si bellissima assegnato uno
che era morto un toast molto per terra
come l'odio pong
non c'è mentre in modalità primo podio
si esatto
no è fighissimo luogo è meno sicura 33
parate di arrivare a 500 sfiga ma si è
data è un gioco dove ti fai più avuto
qualche altro proprio ok all audio sta
roba che ci sono due sì sì non è vero
perché la sua sempre bassa di sarcina
ma se parco lemonia ma com'è possibile a
cribbio 4 mio 34 44 siano modalità
pongono ong modalità bong e poi trovato
chi fa questa build
non possiamo farne 15 54 anni
la prima dove in 54 54 legge ma aiuterà
blocco
ora che veramente i quali ci ho messo i
toast non importa mi piace come gioco mi
piace il tuo stile
se sei veramente forse proprio mio amico
sei veramente fortunato e basta si
guarda da me lo dicono tutti questa cosa
non è vero però lei
ok non ci credo ho sbagliato nato grazie
proprio 216 mazzolai sbagliava
ho fatto pure gol mentre gioco vinci
quando sbagliato e sta indirizzando
tutto e cos'è nello sbagliato nella tua
sbagliato e ai credibile un fondoschiena
gigantesco no sono introdotti del resto
se io aver non ci vado perché avevo
posto incastrati male proprio bene io
sono caduto è stato portato si è un
campo molto 33 33
ne ho già e già da 3 a 1 di prima esatto
non è vero sono usciti successo lo scemo
perché volevo venire davanti ho
sbagliato tasto e dai con sbagliato no
no no c'è proprio nei cessi che c'è una
negazione non capisce perché c'è quello
per terra il viaggio carta ok prova ci
credo però si soffre iozzino pressati
dai per player che come ha insegnato tra
l'altro siamo 1 a roma
questa sta durando molto di più c'è più
skin si sente si sente
nella ski proviamo facili da terzo a 7
l'innata per ora ti lascio bruciare i
cosi che ne pensi le giocate sono
bruciano simbolo crisi non può non certo
noi non lo sapevo ciao pro sono da
rivedere
ciao oddio no arrivo però arrivò prendi
questo dato che sfiga mio dio dai seri
balza in avanti era bellissimo che sta
impegnando tantissimo a non solo mio
questa mini è difficile questa è davvero
difficile ma va bene perché io stavo
facendo cose significa no no non ce
n'era non mentire stola mio avanzo mi
piace avanzare al labbro basta smettila
ri dimentico con tosto bruciato perché è
più buono guarda se mi stai rimontando
addio che culo oddio ragazzi che ha
visto il mio lato ha visto qualcosa di
già visto l'inferno si sia visto
l'inferno ha più volte ora l'altra ma ho
preso cosa per far andare giorno andato
giù andato su no no no no non ci credo
sì sì non c'è parola forse vacca dai che
cesaro su dati osserva che vinco anche
perché non si bruciano i toast scambia
mio dio che paura non è vero sindaco me
è saltato male a 34 ora come è saltato
ma l'idea mi è saltato completamente
storia
oddio no dai
let's be friends dai ultima dai 12 a 1 t
la possibilità di pareggiare chi segna
vince ma che dici vabbè ma se vinci
questo
verso precisi si partì male no che
fastidio partì malissimo ma questa 5a
z500 va bene
oltre cinquanta stato lo giuro ho
sbagliato pensavo di avere il toast
guarda bene mi guardero toaster non
faremo in maniera regolare del genere io
mi sento un breve le triple di 28 mi
sento veramente viola e guarda guarda
guarda questa scusa note di olaso
nell'intimo nord alla sconfitta di
lorenzo no da te per te lo deve fare
qualcosa
no dai non lo riguardasse no longer
affronto mia il foligno che si no oddio
meno male è andata bene ce lo hai fatto
punto programmi che ricordi cosiddetto
50.500 va bene 50 sotto la giunta ei la
ciao 42 allora che ci servono recupero
essere difficilissima che paura noi e
che ha saltato storto me non va bene lo
stesso non avrò non avrò non sono 43 la
macro comunque della piccolina è
difficilissimo adesso si guarda qua
succede al 4 4 finale fa tra l'altro
sono contraria tissimo gli ho fatto fare
sia attenzione siamo post partita e
quindi strategie contro gianpi abbiamo
ancora un punto tocca andiamo è no no no
no perché era
chi segna vince ma io penso che segna
vinci in questa partita e non mi
dispiace ha capito male signor fry
per favore dica qualcosa dica qualcosa
al pubblico per quanto riguarda insomma
questa sconfitta
io ho sbagliato amici nella mia vita
grazie la reazione st impagabile per
oggi è tutto una buona serata linee allo
studio